the Broward County Sheriff's Office said
nineteen year old suspect Nicholas Cruz
had an AR semi-automatic rifle in his
possession when he was arrested it's an
extremely popular rifle and has been
used in mass shootings in Aurora
Colorado Newtown Connecticut San
Bernardino Sutherland Springs Texas and
in Las Vegas
this happens nowhere else other than the
United States of America this epidemic
of mass slaughter this scourge a school
shooting after school shooting it only
happens here not because of coincidence
not because of bad luck but as a
consequence of our inaction we are
responsible didn't take him long to go
right to gun control Chris Murphy from
Connecticut is this a problem with the
gun or the shooter let's look at the air
15 what makes it so popular and
overwhelmingly what makes it so safe
what it takes to get one joining us now
is Aaron Cohen a security and counter
terror expert Aaron you know this weapon
well I fired it many times you know my
family owned a lot of guns
I shot guns since I was out and I was 6
6 years old but it's it it's like all
weapons it's very dangerous in the hands
of the wrong person and if you're not
trained and if you have a criminal
disposition a violent disposition it can
be turned into a killing machine but
Chris Murphy wants to make this tonight
all about the weapons well Chris Murphy
Laura isn't really qualified to a assess
threat and B he's not qualified to
manage risk this is a security issue
it's not a weapon issue that kid had
parents where's the parents who raised
this kid what was going on in the house
that's that's the first place to be
looking we and a pardon me for my voice
there is a mental health epidemic here
which is being confused for a gun
problem I don't want that to sound
political but it's the truth
your last guest talked about how Israel
managed
- completely squash all of the school
shootings in the 70s which were a result
of terrorism the reason why we're able
to do that is because we took a
realistic approach to the security for
the schools which meant multi layering
the weapon just to go back to your first
point the a R stands for Armalite it's
very important for people to understand
doesn't doesn't stand for automatic
rifle armor like the company that
manufactured it for the military
now there's dozens if not hundreds of
companies that manufacture ARS and sell
them around the country is it
semi-automatic rifle which means every
time you depress the trigger it fires
one bullet it's no different than a
handgun it works at the same exact
principle as the handgun in fact around
is even smaller it's a 22 caliber round
if you were to break it down which is
the two to three rifled round the other
difference is it doesn't and will never
be legally purchased to fire without a
Federal Firearms License on full
automatic the m4 which the AR is modeled
after is a fully automatic rifle
deployed primarily in the military by
SWAT units by law enforcement for fully
automatic fire you cannot fire this AR
on full auto I think there's some
grandiosity after being at war for the
last 15 years which makes kids and
people want to associate with this
weapon but the fact is it looks like a
menacing m4 not even close it's a
semi-auto weapon and but the magazines
the clips can hold more bullets correct
that's that's cool that's what Warren
you tackled with limiting the clip size
current so forth so that that's what the
Chris Murphy will say not only is it's
not just the way the weapon looks it's
the fact that the clip holds as many
bullets and if you didn't have a clip
that held that many bullets he couldn't
have done that much damage he had a lot
of clips in his possession apparently
but this weapon it the medal of industry
it's all over the country because it's a
really good self-defense weapon I would
have one in my home for home defense I
thousands of people have them in their
home because it shoots very straight you
can carry more ammunition in it and it's
actually safer because you're gonna have
less like the less
have a lower loss you have to pardon me
I'm teaching a course in Hebrew and now
I'm all over the place you have a less
likelihood of sporadic fire or hitting
innocent people if you're using it for
home defense because it shoots really
straight so it's actually a very safe
weapon yeah it's easier to shoot than a
pistol it's got more points of contact
for stability but in the in the hands of
the wrong person and again where was the
parents where what was the home line for
this child there's so much more involved
here than the guy Chris is so far out of
left base Aaron Willie there are some
things we've learned his mother died
last year he was adopted his parents
Linda Linda and Roger Cruz he's followed
apparently according to trace Gallagher
the Iraqi fighters online and the Syrian
resistance now maybe he was just
following them I guess curious let red
flag up we don't know more but there's
something something something going on
there so we will learn more about that I
one more question for you given your
experience with Israel in the schools
and the bezel on massacre in Russia
remember that that was horrific hundred
people died under Platteville
what could these schools in the United
States do today beyond having one
security guard and a buzzer and some
some bulletproof glass on the front what
else could they do
thank you for asking me this important
question the difference between Israeli
security and American private security
is that we invest in the security guard
we physically train them to be able to
look at behavior to predict violence
which means the average security guard
is trained in a being able to respond to
an active shooter which means they are
all armed in the schools number one to
open the jacket check the bag this kid
had had his jacket opened what the bag
was opened you're not getting in with an
AR you're not getting in with a pistol
you're not getting in with a bomb it
works for it works for idiots like this
kid who are poorly raised and it works
for terrorists and not only do we have a
mental health problem we have a
terrorism problem in this country so we
checked the bags open the jackets but we
train the security we invest in the
individual security guard so he can
predict behavior there's 21 different
red flags someone's going to do when
they're about to commit an act can
commit an act of murder you can train
them in that just spend the money on the
any teaching we're in for Aaron thank
you so much for the insights tonight
take care of that voice